[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the oneplus 7 not the oneplus 7 pro
the oneplus
7 it's that phone that you might have
forgotten existed but if you know
anything about oneplus phones it became
pretty familiar pretty quick so we had
the oneplus 7 pro already i've raved
about this phone and i'll link the full
review below if you want to check it out
the 7 is just like the oneplus 6t but
refreshed for this year so we already
have the oneplus 6 it got refreshed a
couple months later became the oneplus
6t
so this is like a oneplus 6t
t so it doesn't have any of the crazy
features of the pro it's just a solid
steady phone making all the safe moves
for a lower price it has a teardrop
notch instead of the pop-up camera it's
their classic 1080p 60hz oled display
they've been going with instead of the
crazy 1440p 90hz oled of the pro it has
their 20 watt dash charger instead of
the crazy 30 watt warp charging it has a
regular vibration motor instead of the
amazing one from the pro and it has a
healthy six or eight gigs of ram instead
of an absolutely massive up to 12. and
has one less camera it drops the ultra
wide and it's just the standard camera
and the telephoto i wish they'd kept the
standard and the ultra wide like the
s10e since i believe the ultra wide is
way more useful and more fun than a
telephoto and i feel like everyone's
realizing this in 2019 but that's not
what they did still a 2x so basically
you can think of this as either a
stripped-down oneplus 7 pro or what i
think is more accurate
a refreshed oneplus 6t
and what they've done is kept a lot of
the things that people liked about the
oneplus 6t which by the way was a pretty
good phone won my phone of the year last
year and they've continued it in this
one so now it has the snapdragon e55
still the newest chip it's got that
clean oxygen os with frequent software
updates and if you haven't already
noticed this one is running the android
q beta so that's why it's got a little
bit of a different look and the
different buttons and quick settings etc
oneplus phones are some of the only ones
that can get the betas this early the
alert slider is still here awesome as
always although for whatever reason it's
just a little bit smaller just a little
bit
it has six or eight gigs of ram like i
mentioned it's not 12 but it's still
more than the pixel for example can say
right now and then the front speaker
grille and the speaker itself are a
little bit bigger it doesn't make a huge
sound difference for music and videos
but low-key it is a bigger target area
to hold the phone up when making phone
calls so that's nice matter of fact
there are certain things to like more
about the 7 than the 7 pro for certain
people so for example it's a smaller
phone and plenty of people including me
felt the 7 pro is just a little bit on
the big side so the size of the 7 is
more comfortable on the hand more
pocketable easier to reach the tops and
corners things like that there's not
that many compact flagships you know and
it's a flat display instead of a curved
one that sort of bleeds over the edges i
talked about this in the seven pro
review i'm not the biggest fan of the
curved glass and the extra glare and the
accidental touches that'll come with
that so i'm pretty happy with the flat
display and then just little things like
it's a little bit more likely to be
water resistant thanks to the complete
lack of moving parts no pop-up camera so
no worries about durability and of
course the phone is cheaper starts at
500 pounds so the oneplus 6t
t aka oneplus 7 i feel like if oneplus
only released this phone this year and
no oneplus 7 pro we'd all still kind of
know this is obviously an incremental
improvement over last year but that
wouldn't be such a bad thing because we
already know the oneplus 6t was already
a great phone
but so many other things have happened
in the phone world in just the past
couple months that this relatively minor
improvement just got really easy to fall
on the radar you can also get it to
stand out or look a bit different if you
want with a skin from our channel
sponsor d brand if you want to also
since they don't make any matte black
version of this phone this year you got
to take that upon yourself to get rid of
fingerprints and speaking of take it
upon yourself if you really do want to
import this phone you have to take it
upon yourself and pay a little extra for
the shipping to get it to your region
and make sure the bands work with your
carrier of choice and all that which
they usually do but it's worth checking
so if you just search oneplus 7 on
google or youtube or anything like that
you will get bombarded with oneplus 7
pro
photos and videos and articles and
everything it's so easy to forget that
this oneplus 7 exists
why
why did this phone fall
so far under the radar well there are
two main reasons one that i love and one
that i don't love so much to start with
the one i don't love so much this phone
is so under the radar because
that's where oneplus put it like they're
not launching this phone in the us so
it's focusing more heavily on europe and
asia but also oneplus is actively moving
their brand positioning from straight up
budget to much more premium and part of
that is attacking the higher margin
higher price market so not only is
oneplus 7 pro a great phone but that's
what it's doing for them legitimizing
their more expensive products they're
going from flagship killer to
hey we also make a flagship
fine but the other reason it's under the
radar is because
everyone else is kind of putting it
there the competition is putting it
there there has never been more
competition at this sort of premium
mid-tier price than there is right now
asus zenfone 6
samsung a70 redmi k20 pro
pixel 3a pocophone 2 is probably coming
out soon it's lit so this is your psa
that the oneplus 7 is an option to
import for the price
but it's just that now it's an option
it's not the clear front runner anymore
and it's got a whole bunch of very
interesting competition in that little
slot from like 300 to 600 that being
said i do still really like this phone
there's a lot of things from that phone
of the year that it takes and continues
and i can see myself using it every day
and that's not something i say about
every phone so that says a lot about the
oneplus 7. and it also represents that
shift in priorities for oneplus as a
company and just the markets in general
and it also represents a very crowded
radar which if you know what i know
about competition is a good thing for
all of us
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace